Let's look at some
examples of one
dimensional elastic collisions
with no external forces
between two particles.
So suppose I have
particle 1 and particle 2,
and we have them moving
on a frictionless surface.
And let's choose
a reference frame
in which we'll
call-- the laboratory
frame-- in which the initial
velocity of particle 2 0.
So our frame is called
the laboratory frame.
And in this frame we're thinking
of particle 2 as our target.
And the target is at rest.
And particle 1 is moving in
with some initial velocity.
And so here is our
initial picture.
And then in our final
state, both the target
and the particles can be moving.
So we'll just indicate v1 final.
And we'll have target was
also moving with v2 final.
And we have i hat.
So let's now look
at some examples
where we're analyzing
this type of collision
in which both energy and
momentum are constant.
And for a particular example
that we want to look at,
we'll have m2 is twice m1.
Now, for our two equations that
we're going to write about,
we'll choose components, and
we'll write our energy equation
as 1/2 m1 v1 x initial
squared plus 1/2 m2--
so now we're going
to write 2 m1.
But object 2 is at
rest, so we don't have
to worry about that one yet.
And so, our initial
kinetic energy
is just equal to the
final kinetic energy--
1/2 m1 v1 x final squared.
And now I'm going to substitute
in 2m1 for the mass of m2
v2 x final squared.
And that's our energy condition.
And then our
momentum condition is
that the incoming
momentum, 1/2 x initial
is equal to the outgoing
momentum, m1 v1 x final.
And again, I'm going
to substitute for m2.
That's 2m1 v2 x final.
And these two
equations represent
a system of two equations
with two unknowns.
We'll treat this as givens
along with the initial velocity
of particle 1.
And our target here is to
solve for the 1x final and v2 x
final.
So we have two equations
and two unknowns.
Now it's a quadratic equation.
So we have to identify-- from
a problem solving strategy,
we have to identify
which quantity
we're going to solve first.
And so, let's solve
for v1 x final, which
means we need to
eliminate v2 x final.
And the way I'll
eliminate v2 x final
is I'll use the
momentum equation.
And notice that
the m's will cancel
in the momentum equation.
And so, if I divide through
by 2m in the momentum equation
and bring this term
over to the other side,
equation 2a becomes
v2 x final equals--
I'm dividing through by 2--
1/2 v1 x initial minus 1/2 v1 x
final.
So this gives me a
target-- v2 x final--
I can substitute into there.
This equation, again,
can be cleaned up.
Let's clean it up before.
We can get rid of the halves.
We can get rid of the m1's.
And so the quadratic
equation that we're
going to be working with
is v1 x initial squared
equals v1 x final squared.
And I'm dividing through by 2.
So I have the factor 2
plus 2 v2 x final squared.
Now that's our energy equation.
And here's our
momentum equation.
So if we substitute
this in and square it,
we can now substitute and we
get v1 x initial squared equals
v1 x final squared plus 2.
Now we make our substitution.
So that's 1/2 v1 x initial
minus 1/2 v1 x final,
quantity squared.
So let's now expand this.
And we have to be careful
not to make any mistakes.
v1 x initial squared
equals v1 x final squared.
Now if I pull the 2 out,
I got a quarter in front,
and divide that by 1/2.
So I get 1/2 v1 x initial
squared plus another 1
plus a 1/2 v1 x final squared.
Those represent the--
squaring out those two terms.
Now the cross-term will
have a factor of 1/2
in the front but a factor of 2.
So we have a simple cross-term
of v1 x initial v1 x final.
Now, when we--
let's collect terms.
Let's bring everything
over to this side
so we have a 0 equals 3/2 v1
x final squared minus 1/2 v1
x initial squared and minus
v1 x initial v1 x final.
Now I always like to just
write this up in a simple way
to use the quadratic formula.
So I'm going to
divide through by 2/3.
And I get minus 1/3 v1 x
initial squared minus 2/3 v1
x initial v1 x final.
And this is now a
simple application
of the quadratic formula.
Negative b is plus 2/3 v1
x initial plus or minus.
And we're going to interpret
those two roots in a moment.
We have to factor 2/3 v1 x
initial squared minus 4ac.
So that's another
minus sign with a plus.
So that's plus 4/3
v1 x initial squared,
all to the square root, and
everything divided by 2.
Now here, let's just
look at this factor.
This is 4/9 plus 4/3.
4/3 is 12/9, so
that's 16/9, which
is very convenient, because when
you take the square root that's
4/3.
So we get equal to 2/3 v1 x
initial plus or minus 4/3 v1 x
initial divided by 2.
Now we see that there's
two different roots.
So when you add them, you get
2 v1 x initial divided by 2.
So there's one solution.
And when you subtract them,
you're getting 2/3 minus 4/3.
That's negative
2/3 divided by 2.
So that is another solution--
v1 x final equals negative 1/3
v1 x initial.
Now let's think about
the meaning of these two
possible solutions.
This solution has v1 x
final equals v1 x initial.
So that's the
initial conditions.
Just repeat it.
And that will
always be the case.
One solution will describe
the initial state,
and the other solution will
define the final state.
You can check for
yourself that if you just
put vx1 final into this--
equal to vx1 in the initial--
into this momentum
equation, then v2 x final
is 0, which just repeats
the initial conditions.
So this solution is
the initial state.
And this solution, here,
is the final state.
Now just to complete
the picture,
v2 x final-- well,
that's equal to 1/2 v1
x initial minus 1/2
times v1 x final.
But v1 x final is negative 1/3.
So we have a 1/2 minus
1/2 half times minus 1/3.
So that's 1/2 plus 1/6, which
is 4/6 or 2/3 v x initial.
So that's 2/3 the v1 x initial.
And that represents the solution
to this particular problem.
Now, of course what
you want to do is,
you want to check-- we know
the momentum condition is
already satisfied.
But just as a check,
you would like
to put it into the
energy condition
just to make sure that when
you square these things out
you get the right terms.
However, we're very
confident of our result,
because we've already reproduced
the initial conditions.
And that wouldn't happen if we
made some algebraic mistake.
So that, by itself,
is a sufficient check
that this is a correct solution.
One thing we should sit
back and think about
is that when we use
the energy and momentum
that we're inevitably
dealing with quadratics.
And so we expect to use-- to
solve a quadratic equation
at one point.
And here it was right here.
Now we're going to
find another way
to do this by linearizing
the system, which
will be a lot easier.